permettre aux automobilistes de relier
les villes de coignières maurepas à la
verrière grâce à un pot au dessus de la
nationale 10 c'est l'un des objectifs du
réaménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne d'après une étude la nationale
10 supporte un trafic de l'ordre de 52
mille véhicules par jour dans cette zone
ce projet est nécessaire pour fluidifier
la circulation
mais une question persiste sur le
financement de l'opération estimée à 25
millions d'euros
on a le financement de l'agglo bien
entendu rdda le financement du
département
honda le financement de l'état mais tout
cela ne fait pas 25 millions et le
projet l'état 25 millions ça fait une
vingtaine de millions
quid du financement régional qu'elle va
faire la région cette question a été
abordée lors du conseil d'agglomération
du jeudi 27 mai mais le président
jean-michel fourgous se veut rassurant
c'est en discussion comme on dit
favorable ne tombe que et que médée
cette période extrêmement controversée
de cette crise sanitaire pour l'instant
on a pas d'abandon des ans des
engagements de nos partenaires une
enquête publique devrait être lancée
début 2000 22 les travaux du
réaménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne devrait commencer en 2024 pour
une livraison prévue à l'horizon 2026